an unusual site for California
[Applause]
famous for its beaches the golden state
has its known is now underwater
a state of emergency with no bounds
more than a dozen people have died
and the desperate search for a
five-year-old who was on his way to
school has been called off because of
the danger to divers or they're found so
far is one shoe
here in Montecito there's a tragic sense
of nostalgia an evacuation order is now
in place five years to the day a
Mudslide killed 23 people
some of the locals include celebrities
like Oprah the sussexes and Ellen
DeGeneres
ever
[Music]
probably about nine feet up mother
nature because Mother Nature is not
happy with us
severe storms have battered the town and
tens of thousands of people have been
without power
ironically drought warnings are the norm
around here so for locals the impact of
the flooding has hit hard a huge Branch
harpooned my roof and I live in a small
Studio
and we could have been killed by it with
over a ton
like I chose to go for a walk today
and count my blessings and see if there
is anybody else I can help neighborhood
solidarity and a dose of normality
helping weather the storm
for now supper chowdry Sky News